i want to start with the time jump uh
the end of this thing i kind of was
caught off guard by it
so lee and rachel did end up getting
back together again it turns out that
sometimes people do find their way back
to each other
lee and i stayed connected all through
college and after graduation lee moved
back to los angeles and for us it was
like no time had passed at all
what was your feeling like getting to
see
into the future for your character what
was that like for you it was actually
really fun because you know um like in
in press they'll always ask your ques
you a question like where do you see
your character in five ten years
and this movie answers that so i didn't
have to think about that you know we're
engaged we're back together we're
reconnected for megan and my character
and um and you see where joey is you see
where l goes
um in her six years how she's grown
she's like riding her own motorcycle now
like that's just it's awesome you know i
loved i loved the time jump i was
actually surprised by it too i loved it
when you read that what it was going to
kind of look like in the time jump is
that what you expected for these
characters
it is what i expected yeah um i do think
that uh
like i mean personally for um rachel and
lee
uh in my personal life i know a lot of
people who've broken up and gotten back
together uh and then ended up together
um personally that happened for me
and sometimes like you learn good
lessons from hard relationships that
don't come back together
and
then you get the rachels and leaves who
do end up back together which is awesome
because i'm a hopeless romantic
i think that possibly
standing there at the carnival
and seeing noah again after all that
time
i couldn't help but think of one thing
[Music]
just because of
well
you know
i feel like the movie sets up for a
fourth movie obviously we all want that
so much in your heart of hearts do you
think let's say even looking ahead
further
do these characters relationships do
they continue or or what what what do
you see happening with these characters
should should it continue on down the
line
i don't know if should is in my pay
grade but i will say that these
characters are definitely dynamic enough
that i feel like you could pick up with
them in the future
i think that
i mean the way vince wrote these
um
honestly these like these human beings
with issues with struggles with growth
uh like you could you could really just
pick up with them at any time whether we
will do that i have no idea um
but you know that's a
something to look forward to and
think about for the future
let's say it was your pay grade to
to pick a era like let's just say any
era in your character's kind of
existence to come back and do a movie is
there anything that kind of sticks out
where would you pick up this character's
story you know honestly i think for for
this generation i think a cool
continuation if it were to ever happen
would be um when they are parents and
they have kids
and uh
kind of doing the um
a similar thing to uh as to molly
ringwald in this movie where she's like
passing down wisdom to the younger
generation uh basically to like her
daughter um and uh and what that would
look like
like how does lee and rachel give advice
and wisdom to their children like what's
going on with
elle's life
how does how does noah
fit being a father
um or is he like the cool bachelor uncle
who like doesn't have kids yet you know
like
it would be i think that would be an
interesting if it were in my pay grade
yeah no for sure i'm totally interested
just hearing you kind of explore that
world in this interview i think that's
fun if you could send the fans off with
any message uh from this movie what do
you think that is
i think a message coming out of this
movie uh would definitely be
um you know like listen
um love
uh and just um
be patient and communicate as like the
best you can like what you're going
through and what you need and um how can
i love you what do you need
and that's kind of let's figure it out
yeah well said well said and i'm taking
notes and i'll remember it
[Music]